bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à l'eure bournot le maire
était sensé et lever les incertitudes
autour des règles qui régiront les
commerces est ce que vous y voyez un peu
plus clair désormais d'abord soyons
clairs nous ne sommes pas contre le
passé ni terre est évident qu'il faut à
tout prix éviter une nouvelle une
nouvelle pandémie
et on se réjouit que de plus en plus de
nos compatriotes se fassent vacciner
la mesure contre laquelle nous nous
sommes c'est une application du pass
sanitaires pour effectivement entrer
dans les centres commerciaux
on pense que c'est une mesure qui est un
affront inacceptable et inapplicable
inacceptable parce qu'elle est
discriminante
pourquoi les centres commerciaux
pourquoi parle dans ce cas là l'ensemble
des commerces et pourquoi les grands
centres commerciaux
ce qui est d'ailleurs contradictoire
puisque ce sont en général les grands
centres commerciaux qui sont les mieux
équipés pour pratiquer les protocoles
sanitaires qui ont déjà été mises en
place et qui ont fait leurs preuves du
caractère inacceptable de cette mesure
nous l'affirmons et puis ensuite quel
côté d'un entendu inapplicable bon quand
bruno le maire dit qu'il faut quelques
secondes
nous avons fait des tests in-situ pour
voir effectivement combien de temps tu
prenais la vérification avec des codes
ça prend un mini mac 30 secondes par
ailleurs il faudrait recruter environ
5000 nouveaux à grande sécurité aux
quinze jours pour assurer le contrôle à
l'entrée des centres
sachant par ailleurs qu'il ferait
filtrer entre les les consommateurs qui
viendrait pour la galerie marchande et
les consommateurs qui gêneraient pour
l'hypermarché ou pour les pharmacies
donc c'est tout à fait inapplicable sur
le terrain et c'est très coûteux enfin
ce qu'ont estimé que pour une porte
d'entrée
le coût mensuel serait le nord de 30
mille euros donc vous imaginez un centre
lançant près qu'il ya dix ans près ça
représenterait un budget supplémentaire
de 100 mille euros de charges pour pour
les commerçants du sang donc voilà
résumée à une mesure qui nous paraît je
le répète inacceptable au inapplicable
nos prenons tout à fait le besoin de de
contrôler ce pas signataire de ce que
nous proposons ce sont des contrôles
aléatoires fait par les forces de police
comme cela était pratiqué d'ailleurs
pour les attestations déplacement le
gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilités jusqu'au bout
quant à cette motion donc vous parler de
contrôles aléatoires mais pour le pass
annie terre ça veut dire
que ceux qui rentreraient dans des
centres commerciaux devront être munis
de pas sanitaire mais qu'il n'y aurait
pas de contrôles force est obligatoire à
l'entrée du centre c'est bien cela oui
tout à fait impasse sanitaires ou avec
soin le qr code soit effectivement un
test pcr de moins de 48 heures avec des
contrôles qui serait pratiqué par les
forces de police comme c'était le cas je
le répète pour les attestations
dépassement donc vous disiez également
que c'était inapplicable un niveau
logistique parce qu'il faut encore que
vous embauchez des milliers de d'agents
de sécurité pour contrôler ce fameux
passe donc si c'est inapplicable ça veut
dire que vous n'allez pas pouvoir
l'appliquer c'est bien cela écoutez on
attend encore le texte définitif du
projet de loi on espère que le
gouvernement va comprendre que c'est
radio sont des mesures dès qu'il faut
qu'elle soit appliquée derrière sinon
effectivement on ne pourra pas appliquer
ces mesures
bon on a compris qu'il y avait eu un
arbitrage de ce week-end qui était
plutôt un trader je dirais du ministère
de la santé par rapport par rapport à
bercy bono le maire nous soutient
certainement dans cette démarche
mais là on a vraiment un problème
pratique je le répète à l'embauché 5000
nouveaux agents de sécurité en quinze
jours en plus pendant le mois d'août un
pendant le mois de juillet est quelque
chose qui est tout à fait impossible à
réaliser en période de 25 ans on ne
pourra pas trouver le personnel qualifié
plus les problèmes de sécurité que vont
poser c'est que devant devant les
centres commerciaux prennent sanitaire
soit les gens vont s'agglomérer et puis
problème également dans certaines zones
où on risque d'avoir des réactions assez
violente de consommateurs qui ne seront
pas autorisés à entrer dans les centres
alors on sait que ce potentiel pas
sanitaire 1 parce qu'il doit encore
faire l'objet d'un débat parlementaire
va freiner l'entrée des gens dans les
lieux publics et va causer un provoquer
des du manque à gagner pour certains
établissements justement que prévoit
l'état pour combler ce manque à gagner
alors les raisons c'est un sujet qu'on a
abordé avec bruno le maire lors de notre
rencontre avec le ministre vendredi
dernier au ministre est prudemment nous
a écoutés on va attendre de voir les
conséquences économiques et ensuite on
avisera
mais il est fort à craindre
malheureusement que
ces mesures de restrictions à l'entrée
des centres commerciaux provoque
effectivement une baisse de file
rotation est donc une belle de chiffre
d'affaires pour les commerçants c'est un
peu le serpent qui se mord la queue
parce que sans se passe sans eau ni
sanitaires sans vaccination c'est un peu
un nouveau confinement
on pourrait nous pendre au nez et ça ce
sera difficile pour les commerces de
s'enlever écouter les centres
commerciaux depuis depuis la réouverture
et même avant du mois de février ont
strictement appliquées les protocoles
sanitaires qui vous étaient imposés
auquel d'ailleurs aux dames on a
collaboré
c'est à dire aussi bien les mesures
barrières le gel le masque la jauge vous
rappelle qu'à toujours une jauge qui est
effective dans les dans les centres
commerciaux d'une personne pour huit
mètres carrés ce qui limite donc le
nombre de personnes à l'intérieur
par ailleurs une nouvelle mesure que la
mise en place de capteurs de co2 pour
vérifier la qualité de l'air qui peut
être renouvelé en permanence dans les
centres commerciaux et à ce jour il n'y
a eu aucun kloster créé dans un centre
commercial menu des études pasteur trois
études fester successifs qui ont été
faites dans les centres commerciaux pour
montrer que ce n'était pas des lieux de
propagation du virus
donc comme je vous le disais nous sommes
maintenant bien en faveur du passé ni
terre en faveur de la vaccination mais
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi
systématiquement les centres commerciaux
sont stigmatisés sont discriminés par
rapport aux autres plateformes de
commerce
je rappelle également qu elles sont
premières font pas que de nombreux
centres de dépistage et le pixi dassault
dont qui contribue par ses actions
citoyennes a dû lutter contre l'épidémie
gontran turing merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions êtes délégué général du
conseil national des centres commerciaux
marcia fou